scientists figure out a new source of  insulin in the brain  we all know pancreatic beta cell  secretes insulin but scientists showed  that choroid plexus which is a structure  secretes cerebrospinal fluid is also  capable of secreting insulin and that  kind of shakes our textbook knowledge  interestingly inside the brain insulin  secretion is triggered by serotonin and  not by glucose that's more interesting  scientists wonder that what is the role  of local insulin in the brain and why a  local insulin source is at all required  in the brain all these questions are  unanswered but in near future a new  mechanism can be revealed that's one  minute subscribe for more